I'd like to think that the dumbest one that was pitched is in the
game. I can't imagine us going. Wow.
That's really dumb that doesn't belong in a friendship. No dumb,
funny things is what all friendship moves are about. Hi, my name is ed boon.
I am the creative director at another realm studios.
We are about to go through every single friendship move in mortal Kombat 11.
A friendship move is a friendly version of a fatality.
After the reactions to some of our fatalities from the early mortal combat
games, we decided to create the Antifa fatality friendship.
A friendship is a childish, funny,
novel finishing move that the players can do when they don't want to really do
something too violent. And we're going to cover all 37 characters,
including our three new fighters,
rein Molina and Rambo who joined the roster as part of mortal Kombat 11 ultimate
and combat pack to
Baraka's friendship moves actually based on his friendship,
moved from mortal combat to way back in the nineties,
we had much less sophisticated presentation.
Baraka used to just take out a present and present it to his opponents.
Now in 2020, we can do much more of an elaborate performance.
Now he takes out the Cape, he throws it up in the air.
He cuts it up and there's just this big new mess.
So we're just kinda playing on that original idea,
but updating it with a much more elaborate presentation.
Cassie's friendship move is kind of like our social commentary on what younger
people are doing these days. And so it's all about the selfie.
It's all about social media and creating a persona.
It's funny that she went through this crazy brutal fight.
And then as a celebration,
she takes out her cell phone and begins to kind of document what she looked like
after the fight.
I always found that friendship move one of the more humorous ones in the game.
I think every single friendship move that we do,
it'll be one out of four or five ideas that are being pitched.
And then based on the complexity of it, how funny we think it is,
how dumb we think it is. If we think a friendship was dumb,
that's usually a really good sign.
The whole point of these things is to be silly, to be the opposite of vitality,
to get laughter out of somebody rather than shock,
because we have almost 40 friendship moves in the game.
A lot of the ones that we did not use, I've somehow forgotten all about sex.
If you're familiar with such Rianna,
she's all about balance and she's all about good and evil.
So her friendship move is also all about.
Balance. It.
Brings up a tree, it's all about nature and everything,
and then generates a swing and is the swinging and enjoying the
balance of nature. It's not an elaborate friendship,
but it certainly reflects her personnel.
Divorced.
She has always had ties with the insect world.
It actually starts out a little bit dramatic.
She turns into a cocoon and then the exact opposite of what you're expecting
happened. She basically burst out as a butterfly.
The irony of she's always been the most disgusting representation of
bugs and then kind of coming out at the other end of the spectrum with this
butterfly is quite fitting for her. If we were to give her a friendship.
Aaron Black is a gunslinger.
We figured what is the most non-threatening use of guns that we can think of
Love the way this friendship moves starts really dramatic.
You kind of see his head tilting up almost like a Clint Eastwood movie.
And then we quickly transition to a carnival shooting.
Gallery and you see.
Glimpses of this idea used for other friendships.
We're going to see something similar to that in the future, but this whole,
how quickly he does a quick shot is probably one of my favorite kind of like
setting that's created in this friendship with Aaron Black.
Frost.
Like Sub-Zero having this kind of cold power.
You knew it was going to have something to do with ice.
We decided to make an ice skating rink.
One of my favorite things about this particular friendship is the
animations. We don't have an ice skating rink in our motion capture studio,
but somehow our animation team and mo-cap team duplicated the
feeling of ice skating. And so she's skating around the arena.
Her spinning move at the very end is,
is particularly funny just because her head stays still while her body kind of
rotates it.
I still don't know how those guys pull that one off much of what gives the
realism in terms of the feel and look with our games is the fact that we grab a
lot of our animations through motion capture.
So we have motion capture talent come in.
We actually have them perform the moves for frost.
What was so particularly exciting is the fact that we did not have a skating
rink so we could not capture it live,
but our animators can really perform miracles as far as getting the
perfect look and feel. So it was a combination of motion capture,
but a lot of animation magic put on top of it.
That Fujin is the God of wind.
Naturally. We wanted to have his friendship move be of him flying a kite.
He experiences all the struggles that a kid does trying to get the kite in the
air. He decides to use his powers, make the kite get off the ground.
What's so funny about this friendship for me is that he's actually skipping,
he's skipping like a child,
which is so kind of in the spirit of what friendship moves are. In retrospect,
I wish that we had Raiden come out. Who's food brother flying the kite together.
I think it would have been just that extra kind of own for it,
but we could not be happier with how this friendship movie turned out.
It's easily. One of the most playfulness in the entire game
Garris is one of the more, almost random and confusing friendship moves.
We really.
Were kind of thinking,
what do you do with somebody who has control over the sands of time?
And of course you take those sands and build a sandcastle.
One of the funny details I love about it is the concentration that Charisse has
as he's pudding that last flag on the top of the castle,
he's got his tongue sticking out.
Like he just wants to put it in the exact right place.
My favorite part is his arms folding at the end,
looking at his masterpiece. And he's so happy and proud of it,
that facial expression really sells the whole thing for me.
Every single thing that we can do now is something I wish we had back in the
day. The technical struggles way back in the nineties were as
big of a challenge as coming up with the original ideas.
You came up with the ideas and that was great,
but then how do you do it when you're kind of inside this box?
Now the box is gigantic. It's a much different challenge,
but the capabilities are almost limitless.
At this point.
Jade's friendship is based on her staff. And when we were thinking, what,
what do kids do with something like a staff? The idea came up up, up Kenyatta.
So Jade swinging her staff at UPenn,
Jada and hundreds of pieces of candy flying out is a very fun friendship move
for the team to make.
What I love is the nuance of her clapping is so happy with herself,
sitting down with her legs crossed and being almost kind of overwhelmed at how
much candy is in front of her excitement, almost taking over her.
And she doesn't even know which piece of candida it takes.
So she's kind of frantically grabbing every piece of candy that she can even
spot that lasts moments there,
where she's just in bliss is really what sells this friendship move.
Most of the time we look at the character in terms of their abilities or
something about their costume that really stands out based on those ideas,
what is reasonable for us to create? We will pick the right one,
but normally there is a thread of a connection between the
character and the friendship move.
Sometimes it's a lot more of a obvious connection and sometimes it's a bit of a
stretch,
but those ones that are a bit of a stretch are actually sometimes the funnest.
Ones.
Jackie's friendship is the character wanted to do something,
something screwed up. And that's the kind of visual gag.
Jackie takes out like a punching bag and she's using these kind of high-tech
arms, you know, kind of showing them off, punching this kind of rocking,
punching bag.
She thinks that she gave it the final blow and then it surprises Jackie and the
audience and hits her, obviously, because it's a friendship,
she doesn't get upset about it, but it's certainly a bit of a surprise.
And that's the kind of visual gag.
So hers is kind of like the first something went wrong scenario that we have in
the game. Jack's his friendship move.
You can almost call Jack's plays the sax.
He is one of the.
The simplest, but stylized friendship moves in the game.
The music and the camera are some of the biggest parts of what gives this
friendship move the style.
He's got the subtle kind of dancing going the 70 shots with the multiple
versions of jacks. I love the background graphics.
Some people don't notice that when he ends it,
he's actually playing the mortal Kombat theme.
I love those kinds of nuances that we put in there. Jordan, Johnny cage,
his friendship obviously has to be related to showbiz.
We wanted to add something unexpected. So he snaps his fingers.
The lights go out and suddenly we're on a stage and he does this little
dance number with a, a hat and cane. The dancing is purposefully hokey.
That's part of the charm of it is he's not professional dancer,
but he's so arrogant that he thinks he can pull any of that stuff off.
The little leg trick that he does at the very end is funny. And when he ends it,
his hands are kind of doing like a jazz hands thing.
If you watch that friendship move a number of times,
you'll pick up on little nuances, just like that.
John Rambo's friendship is laser tag.
I love the way it starts.
It has a clear reference to the Rambo movies where he's suiting up.
You think that something serious is going on,
but when he clicks that gun and you see it light up, you know,
something's different. And boom,
we switched to this laser tag situation where he's in front of and hiding
behind the two inflatable cover walls. We go through a sequence of his head,
popping up, taking shots at opponents,
crawling between the two shooting in a variety of ways. It's a classic.
It's not what you think it is. Kind of scenario it'll.
Be right between the eyes.
John Rambo helps finish out our goal of getting as many eighties action
stars in mortal combat. We've had Terminator. We've had Robocop.
You are under arrest dirt bag and now John Rambo.
So he really bookends that whole guest character roster that we have going.
Shoes are either a benefit or a hazard.
The thing about the licensed characters that was such a pleasant surprise for us
was that we make the characters do such silly things.
We were really concerned that the,
the owners of the license would have an issue with us doing something as,
as yet, but with Rambo, with Robocop, with Terminator,
they were such great sports about it.
That was one of the most pleasant surprises in all of this was how enthusiastic
they were with having their characters play along in this silly portion of it.
A game, which is the friendships joker.
It has been in a number of NRS games over the years in mortal Kombat 11.
It's probably the darkest representation that we've had.
It was fun to see him back again in a lighter tone, like Jackie,
his friendship move is another, something went wrong. It starts off.
He's trying to do something really sinister with a gun from out of the blue.
The battery comes out and hits him in the back of the head.
He actually even references Batman.
And then he switches over to taking out some balloons.
At the end of the day, he says, I'm sorry.
So it's kinda like the batarang kinda snapped him back into place into the more
kinder, gentler joker.
We really wanted to have it be like a hint of Batman.
We certainly didn't want to have him just come out and then everybody's going to
be wanting to play him. If we actually created his model for the game,
we've used joker three times before a mortal Kombat versus DC and justice one
and injustice two in the T rated games.
We didn't want to kind of go crazy with him in terms of his,
his violent side and in mortal Kombat 11 that's when everything kind of went
loose,
throwing joker into the mix with the mortal combat game.
That's when you really get the opportunity to take off all the rains and
have him do crazy.
Six stuff, cabals friendship.
Probably one of the most random friendships in the game.
He zips onto the screen.
And there's this gigantic xylophone.
That he starts playing.
Probably what I'm most impressed with this friendship is the animation.
It is perfectly synced to the music that is playing.
You would never think that those were two separate efforts that were done by
different team members. Again,
another subtle reference to the mortal combat song.
I don't know how they manage to time that so perfectly,
that's a tribute to our animation and audio team working together as random
as it was. It's definitely one of the more entertaining friends.
Cantaloupe.
It was one of our more direct friendship moves.
Everybody thinks of Keno Australian shrimp on the Barbie.
So in some respects, we had to do what we did.
Kendall uses his eye laser to start.
A barbecue and he's got brought worse or something on there.
If you look closely,
you will notice that there are shrimp on that barbecue.
I wish we had him pick up a shrimp. It would have been a more direct reference,
but for the people who are looking for those details, yes,
I can confirm that are shrimp on that Barbie
Gitanos friendship move is probably the most friendliest and perhaps
innocent or child
Mortal Kombat 11 was released. Everybody has been clamoring for a Molina.
I used to kind of troll people by saying, you know,
technically Molina is in the game because she's in Katana's
friendship, move where they play Patty cake.
They're traditionally very bitter rivals.
But the irony of seeing them play together like sisters who grew up together is
what is so cute about this friendship move. I love at the very end.
There's like this nuance where they actually mess up and then they both realize
it. And they both laugh. That's what kind of like bonds them together.
So they kind of give each other a big hug, realizing that they messed up.
They're just celebrating their, their sisterhood collectors.
Friendship is called a one man band friendship.
He pulls out a number of instruments. There's drums. There's a horn,
there's a flute, there's a guitar. And he's playing them all at the same time,
a one man band. You really got to look at that one,
a number of times to see the nuances that we put in that friendship move
again, everything is synced up from the cymbal, hits to the horns,
all perfectly synced with the music. The fact that he had forearms,
I guess in reality,
we could have done that with Sheba or Gora or Tara or any one of the forearm
characters,
but the collector was the one who we thought it matched a little bit.
He's probably a little bit more sophisticated than the monster type characters.
I'm sure that whoever animated it, it was a huge challenge to me. It's like,
like a hyper version of walking, chewing gum,
rubbing your stomach at the same time.
The fact that it has to be in tune with the music and the individual four or
five instruments that he's playing at the same time.
I can't imagine being the one who has to kind of coordinate all of those things
together.
Kinsey.
Cons friendship is perhaps the shortest and the simplest like Fujin.
He is a character who has command of certain elements. Fujin with wind.
Cortile is with the sun. Obviously we thought, okay,
let's have him pull out a lawn chair and get a suntan.
He.
Pulls out a lawn chair, sits down,
gets one of those reflective mirrors to make the most out of his
sunbathing and just chills. One of the nuances you notice, if,
if you stare at his face, he eventually closes his eyes.
I don't know if he's trying to fall asleep or if he's trying to make sure that
his eyelids get also get suntan,
the team put a light source because we really wanted his face to be lit up,
to put something above them and then have it reflect down.
Probably doesn't give us the kind of precision control that we want.
But if you set a light point where the player can't see it,
you can really frame cuddles face with a lot more precision and detail.
Kung Laos friendship is one of the super childish little nuances that kids
do. It starts with his classic teleport.
And then when he pops up a train set appears around his hat,
which is just perfect for [inaudible].
And he is playing with the front engine of the train,
and then he spinning it around.
The nuances that I love of this friendship move is he's kicking his feet
like little kids do when they're watching TV or something like that.
Those little touches that the animation team,
the cinema team puts in there just gives it that little,
extra umph of childlike play that makes these friendship
moves, feel that much more silly, but in some ways,
endearing the old friendship where he throws his hat and the dog goes to
fetch it. And if you keep in mind that his,
his hat is made of razors at the edge and your hair type,
a lot of people got that joke.
I think we didn't want to repeat that one just because things look so much
more real today.
I don't want to see like a dog that looks like a,
we help talk end up with that kind of demise.
Lou King's friendship is it's the return of the disco ball
like Baraka.
It's a remake of an old school friendship move that he had where a
disco ball would come down and he would kind of do this dance
Back in the day. We had very little memory to do it.
So he would just kind of repeat the same animation over and over again.
This time it's a whole set.
You see the lights on the ground, you see the movements. He has choreography,
there's little hints of like a Saturday night fever point that he does the
nuance again of this one I love is he's a little bit awkward.
He's not a professional dancer. There's a certain awkwardness,
which I think is great.
It's a little endearing dorkiness that he has where he's doing the dance.
But at the end of the day, it's Lou King, he's got a lot of nobility.
He hasn't really had much time to learn about dancing and it kind of shows.
Molina.
Friendship. We can call the Teddy bear tea party.
If you notice the three Teddy bears are a Teddy bear of Molina,
Katana and Jade.
And they're kind of like our famous female ninjas in a sense,
whenever one of those characters is not in the game.
Everybody is clamoring for whatever happened to this character.
We've gone through that. A number of times,
I love the way that when Molina sets up this tea party,
she is constantly in the process of making things even better.
She's adjusting the Teddy bears. She's pouring the tea,
her Teddy bear falls over. She picks it up. She's applauding.
She could not be happier to be there.
That tea party is just the perfect kind of summary of the
part of Molina. At the end of the day,
I kind of wish we had done one of those for the male ninjas,
or would have been cool to see scorpion Sub-Zero and rain or something,
do the same thing, but we were able to do it with the females.
And so that worked out great.
NyQuil's friendship is pretty much an animal act, almost like a circus act.
At first, he pulls out this ring lights on fire,
and you're just wondering if there's something more serious,
see a spirit Wolf come out.
What I love is the nuance of him tapping his leg and tasting the,
the Wolf to jump through the hoop. When it does, then everything cuts loose,
where the Eagles flying in. We see the bear in the background,
balancing on the ball, and it's just this big stage circus act.
What I found so entertaining about it is night Wolf, how Intuit he is, you know,
is just coaxing the Wolf to jump through the hoop and how proud he is
holding the Eagle at the very end, like I taught these animals how to do this.
That's such a funny situation to be set up.
This might actually be my favorite friendship. Move in the game easily.
It's in the top three, for me, it starts out with him, splitting into three,
has a clone and then a jump rope sequence.
This was a fun idea. I think it worked out great,
but it was absolutely sold by the performance.
One of our motion capture talent. His name is Nate. He just went crazy with it.
So you see all the nuances.
I've never seen somebody in a motion capture studio have so much
fun contributing to the spirit of one of our
cinematic moments,
the ink splashes on the ground as his hands and his feet make contact with
it is such a rape detail of it. But again,
it's that performance and the animation.
I've never seen something communicate joy so much as to that guy
dancing and jumping rope. At the same time, it was just such a,
such a great performance Reagan's friendship.
Along with Lou King and Baraka,
and a number of other characters is a nod to their original friendship. Move.
Ravens was called kid thunder
And kid thunder makes a return in mortal Kombat,
11 a much more elaborate choreographed like dance
return. So Raiden summons can thunder.
And we hear that kind of familiar kid thunder yell.
We see this great light dance performance,
the detail of him doing that kind of break dance moment.
And you'll notice if you wait until the very end,
he kind of gives us look to his dad,
almost like he's looking for approval or something like that.
You have to see those friendship moves a number of times to pick all of those up
Rain's friendship is the carnival water gun.
The way that it starts,
there's an irony to it because he's sitting in a carnival,
but the camera comes zooming at close and he's holding his finger like a gun.
Like he's going to do some kind of action with it.
And then he points it at this party game that starts filling up the balloon.
And it pops.
I love the way that the actual prize that he wins just falls from the sky and
he's holding it kind of real proud of it and decides to show off a little bit
more by creating a water spout coming from his hand.
And that's kind of elevating the price that he just won.
And it just kind of stays there with him in the sense of pride that he won this
ridiculous stuff.
Animal meaning robot.
Cup's friendship is Robocop. Does the robot.
It's a very retro dance sequence, which looks so ridiculous. Again,
it's another example of how grateful we are that the owners of
these licenses allowed us to do Robocop doing these eighties, nineties,
two thousands, dance nods,
the moonwalk and all the things is such a funny thing to see.
And everybody will kind of make the connection Robocop doing the robot again.
I'm so glad that they allowed us to do something as silly as that
the music and the performance. Again,
this is another one of those friendships where the performance just carries it.
The motion captured that talent that we have,
and the animators just nailed the kind of spirit of what this friendship movie
is trying to do.
Skin scorpion.
Friendship, I guess you can call the, get over here, giant Teddy bear.
It was one of the first friendships that we did where we kind of like set the
tone of the remaining friendships in the game.
He looks like he's going through one of his victory moves where he throws his
spear out the camera's his dramatic angle,
but instead of some victim being pulled in,
it's this big Teddy bear and scorpion just starts hugging him.
One of the details that are in that particular friendship that I hope people
pick up on is as he's hugging the Teddy bear,
he looks up and he acknowledges the Teddy bear one more time and then continues
to hug him. And it's, it's really, uh, so opposite of scorpion moment,
that kind of defines what the spirit of these friendship moves is intended to be
Shang. Tsung's friendship is like some of the others,
a tribute to his mortal Kombat to friendship.
He basically just kind of creates this rainbow.
And it's kind of like this universal symbol for love and everybody getting
along, which is great this time,
he's has this sinister look on his face and he's creating this big spell that
you think something bad is going to come out of. But then all of a sudden,
he just reverts back to that pose with his arms in the air,
opening them up or feeling the rainbow and back to friendship.
It's a little bit of a trick there where he starts sinister,
but then he kind of reverts back to that friendship.
But it's one of our quick and simple friendship moves in the game.
Shout con along Aaron Black and rain is a carnival
related friendship move. Everybody knows. Shout con he's the big hammer.
What do you do with a big hammer? You test your might in a sense.
And of course he shall con so he breaks the bell at the top,
everything shatters, and he's all proud of himself. That's his kind of,
I break the rules type of thing. And that's again,
the kind of trifecta of carnival games that we have in mortal Kombat, 11.
[Inaudible].
Sheila's friendship is she plays the wineglasses.
This is easily the quietest smoothest,
most mellow friendship that we have in the game with these characters that have
forearms. We really try to think of something novel for them to do.
And that Shiva at the end of the day, she probably would prefer piece.
And so we just put a whole bunch of wineglasses in front of her,
and she's just using all four arms to play the soothing music, very Zen,
but also one of the more simple friendship moves in the game.
There's nothing really complex about it.
Just a whole bunch of wineglasses that she plays this little symphony on
Sendell's friendship is another quick and simple one. It's a bit of a gag.
She takes out a wineglass and Sandel is known for her voice,
her scream, her ability to do damage with this voice.
And so you think that she's going to scream and shatter the wineglass,
but as she is screaming,
the camera lens actually cracks.
She gives this sinister laugh and she just takes a
sip of the wine because why not?
I love the kind of a little bit of a gag that's in it where you think she's
going to do the obvious and then something else happens.
I think it might be our only friendship move that kind of breaks that fourth
wall with the player. It's one of the kind of gag friendship moves in our games.
There is no like physical object. That is the lens throughout the game.
We use different fields of view,
depending on how dramatic we want to be with something,
the mood that we're trying to set.
But that friendship is kind of playing on that where it's kind of like, Hey,
don't forget, you're looking at this video game through a lens again,
that's that little nuance of kind of breaking that fourth.
Wall.
Scarlet's friendship can be called the masterpiece.
It starts out a little dark she's painting with blood.
She goes from precision where she's really concentrating.
And then she goes to these crazy moments where she's throwing blood at the
canvas. You're wondering, what is this going to be?
Basically when she reveals it, it's a self portrait.
It looks like a child painted. It makes no sense at all.
The detail that I love about this one is the facial expression that she has when
it's done. It's such a childish painting, but as any artist would be,
she's just as proud as has can be with this very basic self portrait.
Sonya blades. Friendship is probably one of the cuter friendships in the game.
She actually plays fetch with her robot and typical moral combat
fashion. That cute little drone,
which looks like an eighties movie robot comes back and it's dragging this dead
body. The irony being that Sonia, when she sees it,
she goes as if it's something that's really cute that the star of it is her
little robot and it's game of fetch.
Stains.
Spawns friendship is probably the shortest, short and sweet,
and it definitely demonstrates the opposite of a character's personality spawn,
who is just the epitome of hell and violence.
It's a special kind of hell. Isn't.
This crazy Cape suddenly showing him using the Cape as a hammock and
he's reading relaxing again,
the music plays such a big part because it's the saxophone
Absolutely sets the mood.
It's just so not what you would expect spawn to do. And once again,
for the people who created spawn, who allowed us to do this,
we're very grateful.
[Inaudible].
Sub zeros. Friendship is the ice cream truck or ice cream vehicle.
It opens with the most ridiculous animation I'm,
Sub-Zero where he's randomly excited them and runs off the screen.
And you're kind of wondering what, what, what are you so excited about it?
He comes back on the screen with this old school ice cream vehicle.
There's an umbrella overhead written on the cooler is Sub-Zero frozen treats.
You see Gorel with four cones,
one in each hand as scorpion where he dropped us cone.
Cause of course Sub-Zero and scorpion are still rivals at the end of the day.
So he's not going to have a picture of scorpion having fun at the very end.
He generates one of his, the popsicles with, with his freeze power.
Of course it's so child is it's so ridiculous. That's why it works.
The Terminator's friendship is motorcycle tricks.
Terminator has one of his kind of like signature things is his big motorcycle
that he rides on. We thought it would be funny to have him do stunts.
So he leaves.
And then all of a sudden he's riding on the motorcycle and you're like, Oh,
okay, he's going to just exit the scene.
But then he stands up on the motorcycle and he's balancing.
And that smile that he gives to the camera,
that moment is probably the most entertaining part of that friendship.
And then he just begins a process of back and forth riding with handstand.
And then you see him popping a wheelie. There's a charm to it.
The fact that everybody knows that face and everybody knows how serious
Terminator traditionally is seeing Terminator with a smile goofing around in a
friendship. Again, we're so grateful we were allowed to do that.
Just sells that friendship move perfectly.
So that is every friendship move in mortal Kombat 11.
That was a lot to cover.
I hope you learned a little bit about how we design these moves and maybe
thought of a different way.
To finish.